uh
tell us about
randomized versus deterministic decision
tree size
um thanks everyone for coming and
thanks for having me here it's a
pleasure so today I'll be talking about
joint work with uh
yogesh Jai Kumar swagata all of whom are
at various different institutes in India
spread pretty much all around India
um and the odd one out here so um
throughout this talk I'm going to be
talking about Boolean functions and
decision trees uh please feel free to
interrupt me at any point
so the objects of interest in this talk
are going to be
Boolean functions that take n Bits
an input output one bit and unlike some
of the previous stocks we only care
about total Boolean functions so we want
our functions to be defined on the whole
Boolean Cube
now very quickly let me tell you what
decision trees are
so a decision tree is a model of
computation of Boolean functions so a
decision tree uh
is a binary tree where internal nodes
are labeled by variables
you have edges labeled by values in 0 or
1.
and then you have leaves labeled by
values either in 0 or 1.
so this is an example of a decision tree
that computes a four bit function in the
natural way so on input x what this
decision tree does it first checks the
value of X1 if it's 0 go down the left
subtree if it's one good on the right
subtree and then recurse until you hit a
leaf at this point output the value seen
at the leaf okay so this is a decision
tree t
and it very naturally computes a Boolean
function f
uh
that's defined by
X reaches a one leaf
that is a leaf with the label one okay
and
now we care about several uh models of
complexity of decision trees so one
motivation for studying decision trees
is decision trees is a nice way of
capturing what a query algorithm does so
this uh exactly captures a query
algorithm for f in the following sense
first an algorithm queries the value X1
then depending on whether the value is 0
or 1 you make the next query as dictated
by the tree and so on
and the query complexity of the
corresponding algorithm is the worst
case number of bits seen which is
nothing but the depth of the tree
um what we're going to care about as the
title gives away is the size of such
trees
and this is a very nice abstraction from
your usual model of computation where
you actually care about what the
computations are in between these
queries but the query complexity is
abstracts that completely out which is
why it's somewhat nicer and easier to
analyze and has more structural
properties and such
good so let me throw out a bit of
notation that I'm going to be using
so I'm going to use the notation
so for a tree T I'm going to use the
notation Q T of x
uh to denote
um
set
of
variables
so on input X if you run the decision
tree T what is the set of variables
queried I'm just denoting uh using QT of
x to denote this
so we have the natural measure of query
complexity or decision tree complexity
which I am going to denote by D
so uh D of f is the minimum
depth of a decision tree that computes
now we can talk about some general
generalizations of decision trees and
the generalizations that we care about
are going to be those where an algorithm
is allowed to query more General
functions than simply the variables of
the input
so one particular example is where an
algorithm is allowed to query hours of
arbitrary subjects of the input so this
I'm going to denote by D or of f
or decision tree
and what is in all decision tree is just
like instead of nodes being labeled by
variables you allow nodes to be labeled
by
subsets of the inputs
and then
so an example where a very simple
example where an all decision tree is
gives considerable
it's considerably more power than
regular decision trees is for the or
function you can show that D of the or
function is n but D or of the r function
is just one okay
so I'm going to look at D or
D and sorry
the
same definition with or replaced by and
also going to look at D and comma r
and in the and comma or model uh we
allow algorithms to query either ends of
subsets of inputs or ORS
so both I mean both okay
okay
um
and another model that uh
of course it's evident from the title
that we care about is the size of a
decision tree and what's the size let's
just say the number of leaves
and this up to a factor of two maybe is
it equal to the number of internal nodes
but we don't care about constants
so let me say d size of f
instead of minimum depth we have minimum
number of
leaves
of a decision tree that computes f okay
cool so here's the first proposition
that uh sort of motivates in some sense
why we should look at size or why we
should look at and or trees so in some
sense in this query world
uh the depth of an algorithm is in some
sense
um a proxy of time complexity in this
query setting and I want you to think of
and or query complexity or size
complexity as
an analog of space complexity in the
very complexity mode okay it's not quite
true but
let's make some sense I guess
so here the first proposition which is
folklore I guess
um
all Boolean functions have
okay one more thing is whenever I'm
going I'm using the notation Theta tilde
I'm abusing notation a little bit uh
Theta tilde always hides factors that
are poly logarithmic in the input size
poly login factors
so let's look at a proof for this at
least now
one more thing I should mention is that
this D or of f the or query complexity
of f the r query model corresponds to
the setting of combinatorial group
testing that people look at where you
are allowed to query or arbitrary hours
of subsets of the input
okay
so
if you want to show that
um
so let's start with the other direction
because it's easier perhaps
so given uh and or decision tree what
you can do is you can just simply expand
out all ands and ORS by just regular
variables so for example if you have a
node that varies
and you want
so you have t 0 and T1
this you can simply map to
uh
so let's say s is X1 X2 X3 for now uh
sorry one two three
so this is an expansion of a single node
that had an and query into one that has
just variable queries and as you can see
the size doesn't blow up too much like
there's a factor of potentially n that
the size blows up by
um
so in general if you started with a
depth D Tree here
what you're going to end up with is a
size n to the DT or so roughly
so that shows this direction
and for the other direction so I'm going
to hand wave a lot of stuff just feel
free to stop me whenever again
for the other direction we can use this
uh there's this tree balancing or
protocol balancing or argument that you
may have seen in other settings
um
let's look let's start with a
regular decision tree T of size s
uh now you can argue that there is a sub
tree
that contains
a fraction of vertices or nodes that
somewhere between that's a fraction
between one third and two-third of the
original size
so
so what uh you can do efficiently with
an and or query algorithm is you can use
one and query and one or query to
determine whether your input reaches
this node
uh if it does then you've cut down on at
least
one third fraction of the remaining
nodes so you've lost a factor of one
third in the size and if it doesn't
you're again in this subdue which again
you've lost at least a factor one third
in the size so you do this log many
times
and uh
so from a size s uh decision tree you
get a depth log s and or decision tree
so this is
uh
next what we are going to look at uh
again as the title gives away is
randomized measures of decision trees
again very quickly
um
so randomize The View that we are going
to take for decision trees randomized
decision trees in this talk
um
is that a randomized decision tree is a
distribution over deterministic decision
trees
and
what will require
or correctness is that
so we're going to say that a randomized
decision tree T mu so this is a
distribution over decision trees where
the distribution is denoted by mu so we
are going to say t mu computes f
if for all inputs
the probability of it making an error is
small okay so your random you randomly
sample a tree according to tmu run it on
X the probability of making errors
and what are the complexity measures of
a randomized tree uh it's just the worst
case complexity of a deterministic tree
in the support so
r
of f is the randomized analog of perfect
it just came here rof is
um
it's a minimum overall randomized trees
that computes
uh compute
Computing f
maximum
overall T in the support of mu
bof
sorry
so yeah I mean um
minimum depth of a decision tree is just
dot
um so yeah so this is the randomized
query complexity or randomized decision
tree complexity of f
um similarly I'm not just going to write
down everything else but you just put
the word randomized in front of or query
complexity and query complexity or
randomized size as well okay
um other questions of this part what
definition these are
essential yeah
can we assume that it's balanced up to
constant factors or something
um
yeah
good question I
am pretty sure we can
yeah
I'm pretty sure you can get back to you
yeah I am pretty certain argument like
this
foreign
in the early 90s
so basically what Nissan showed is that
in this query complexity setting
Randomness doesn't provide a super
polynomial advantage
uh phrase differently this says that in
the query World p is equal to PPP I hope
that excites some of you
um
and at this point so this is in some
sense a de-randomization of depth and
I'm just going to State our main
theorems
foreign
factor in here that's hiding inside this
o tilde I'll get back to log factors in
the end of the talk but for now let's
say we don't care about them at all
so in some sense this answers the space
analog of whether the randomization is
possible in the query world and it is
up to log factors which we can also get
rid of later spoiler
um so first thing is
this answers an open question that we
had posed in an earlier work
but we have essentially asked this
question in a different language and
interestingly our motivation was from a
completely different perspective we had
posed this with the hope to get more
efficient Quantum query algorithm so
that was a paper about Quantum query
complexity
and using similar techniques as to what
we use to prove this which I'm going to
prove to you soon
we are also able to answer
um
so I should put in a corollary here
for all F total Boolean functions uh
deterministic and or query complexity is
at most a fourth power in randomized and
or two log factors
just by this proposition
so that's our first result
and our first result a second result
sorry we use similar techniques as we do
here slightly more effort Maybe
and for all F Boolean functions
photovolian functions we get
so even the and query complexity of f is
uh Randomness doesn't provide a super
polynomial Advantage discounting log
factors which again I'll get back to
later
and we using the same essentially the
same idea we can prove the same result
for all decision trees as well
okay
and yeah this
sorry
had asked
essentially this question in 2021
whether and decision trees can be
de-randomized
and we answer that in the positive
okay
um
just as a side note before I dive into
the proof I just want to say here
um there's a result of I'm not going to
write down all the authors because it's
going to take me some time but I'll say
it out it's unbiness below this
belovedly Santa and smart drops in 2017.
uh they showed
and I'll write down the initials
so it's not known what the true
polynomial separation is here for all we
know it might be true for all Boolean
functions deterministic is at most
quadratic in randomized for all we know
there exists a function that Witnesses a
cubic separation and this is uh
there's a lot of research going on in
this area I'm sure
maybe 10 20 of the audience here have
thought about this problem at some point
um
any questions at this point
that size oh yes sorry I should have
mentioned this good point so uh
except for this measure here decides all
other measures are depth measures yeah
so and decision trees or decision trees
and or decision trees all depth yes
sure yeah
it's typically harder to analyze I guess
um
yeah I don't know what happens with
respect to bad cells Maybe
improve complexities my might have a
better idea of what happens it's my
guess
okay if there's no more questions I'm
going to sketch very quickly how
Nissan's proof was and then how we
attempt to adapt it to prove our length
here
foreign
[Music]
definition of this combinatorial
quantity called block sensitivity
it will Define
um and then what Nissan went on to show
is via some other combinatorial measures
as well
that uh
small BS
so this just combining these two gives
you this answers
so I'm going to Define block sensitivity
of a function f at an input X
so this is n 0 1 to the n
thank you
[Music]
what's up
this is a bit of a mouthful so let me
just
illustrate with an example so block
sensitivity is uh discounting the number
of
possible sets such that if you flip the
values of your input X completely on
these sets individually then the value
of the function changes
so and I'll just give you an example in
a second
foreign foreign
variables
this outputs one if and only if there's
at least one one in the input okay
and let's look at the input that's 0 to
the N I'm just going to write it out 0
0. so
and now I'm going to claim that every
single turn here
is a sensitive block so in other words
Define s i is equal to I
all of these Si's are disjoint from each
other because they are Singletons and
moreover because the function is the or
function the property is that if you
flip any of these blocks around so if I
change the 0 to a one the function value
changes
and of course you can't have more than n
sensitive blocks because there are n
elements in your whole universe to begin
with
so block sensitivity of our function is
at most n and block sensitivity of r
is n as witnessed by the input 0 to the
N okay
and
um
yeah and in in some sense this
inequality here
is the way the proof goes is you fix a
certain set certain number of variables
such that F becomes an r on BSF many
variables and then you can analyze just
from first principles that the
randomized query complexity or
randomized decision tree complexity of R
is Omega number of variables
questions
okay uh now we're going to attempt to
prove theorem one year
by adapting
Nissan's proof
and my attempt uh
foreign
is going to be very silly
I want to replace D of f by
log D size of f
and
does anyone see a problem with this
so for the or function we have block
sensitivity to be n
but its decision tree size is very small
like log decision precise is just log n
why is this so the r function has a
simple decision tree
0 on the left I guess
so this is size n or n Plus 1.
so in some sense this fact that block
sensitivity captures the hardness of ore
sitting inside it
is a weakness for us because we really
need a function that has large size
that's sitting inside
and what we do to get around that is we
Define this analog of block sensitivity
which is a counting analog
uh which we're going to call block
number
so this fails
it is the
maximum number of minimal sensitive
blocks of F at X so in the OR function
if I'm looking for minimal blocks
there's only n of them because all of
The Singletons are minimal right this is
the maximum
maximum reward funny you're uh you're
right
I just mean number of minimal sensitive
blocks yeah
so for example if I look at the majority
function let's just take an example
Maybe
and I look at the all zero input
um you can check that the block
sensitivity of this is basically like
two one depending on how you define
block sensitivity
but you have several minimal blocks here
like any size any subset of size n by 2
or n by 2 plus 1 depending on your
definition is
minimal sensitive block
and this is I guess our idea of why
um this is maybe a more right measure if
you want to analyze size
several minimal sensitive blocks in some
sense the intuition is that if you have
trees Computing F each of these blocks
correspond to us path you know that's a
very high level idea
um so shortly after we defined this we
realized that this has actually been
defined earlier and the earliest we
could trace it was a work of Kulkarni
and tal
in 2016 or 17
[Music]
foreign
context but not quite the same where
they were looking at fractional versions
of block sensitivity in certificate
complexity and other combinatorial
measures
perfect
um
and now I will finally get down to what
our key structural results are
and hopefully prove at least one of them
foreign
and this is going to be in some sense
weldedness
yes in some sense this is going to be an
analog of
this one let's call this two
uh I'm going to write something that I
haven't defined yet I'm going to Define
it so
so log n f is a quantity that uh
deterministic decision tree size can be
upper bounded by the square of this
quantity I'll Define it in a second so
this first bullet point I want you to
view as an analog of
Nissan's first
inequality and the second bullet point
is uh exactly putting this intuition
that I had phrased in words into a
formal statement
log randomized size is at least log
block sensitive everything is poly log
factors Let's ignore that further
uh let me Define n of f Maybe
it's one
space
so what's an F monochromatic sub Cube
it's just a sub cube of the your
original Boolean cube and a fine sub
Cube where F takes a constant value okay
and N of f is again some sense
and 0 of f which I'm not splitting up
this definition but in this is in some
sense the non-deterministic complexity
of f non-deterministic query complexity
and uh
it's not very hard to show that if you
have an efficient cover of f by sub
cubes then you can actually get small
size decision trees
if
if you've seen it before this just
follows from like d is at most zero
certificate complexity times one
certificate complexity just that
argument if you write it out
you get
log
in size
for the order of
log Square n of f
so
if I put this in over here I substitute
nof and then I substitute
log block number by log R size
um
this
I I hope I haven't written things wrong
but this should imply this
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
leave some space come back to the proof
of this in the end maybe I'm hoping I'll
have time to prove at least one of these
foreign
one
and for theorem 2
um
we use another key intermediate measure
which is not block number but which is
zero fractional heating set complexity
which unfortunately I don't think I'm
going to Define it here I'm happy to
talk about it offline
uh
this is a measure that has been uh
looked at in the past for example this
paper of or the precursor paper to this
of Shahar and others they looked at this
quantity
so what we show here
is
again this is a quantity that I haven't
defined yet
on F
so in other words this this first
statement is somehow a strengthening of
this fact that I said that D is at most
0 C 0 times C1 you can actually make
this stronger and argue that
this complexity which I will Define now
is
also upper bounded in terms of this
cover number
and uh
I haven't told you what the the zero
decision tree complexity of f is so in
zero decision trees you allow arbitrary
variables to be queried
but the depth of a leaf you only count
the number of zero answers that are
there
so for example if you look at the and
function
the zero decision tree complexity of it
is just going to be one because on any
Leaf you are reading at most one zero in
the triviality computing
and it turns out that up to log Factor
Supply log factors d up to a long Factor
D 0 of f is essentially the same as the
and decision tree complexity of F and r0
of f is essentially the same as
the randomized and decision tree
complexity of f
so we get
the end of f
this is a block factors
0 of f sorry
one
foreign
it's not hard to show that r0 of f is at
most
log randomized sizeable
sorry this is my mistake here
Cloud n of f
m
foreign
to show this we need the fact that cover
number is at most sorry log cover number
is at most log Square randomized size of
F and that follows from
our statements here
just plug in this plus this exactly
gives this equality here log n of f is
Atmos log Square our size of a couple
log factors
and r0 of f it's uh given a small zero
decision tree it's easy to come up with
a small size decision tool
and I mentioned earlier that zero depth
complexity is essentially uh and
what
so now what I'm going to do is maybe I
will just verbally give you ideas as to
how we prove these uh and then if you
are interested I can formally prove it
offline okay
so to show this
what we are going to do is we're going
to start with a small size randomized
decision tree for it
and
what I need to do to you is I need to
exhibit a cover of your input space
f monochromatic cover of it
so what we'll do is
um
first look at fix and input X
and suppose it's minimal sensitive
blocks are
W1 through w k
so this is a
hand wavy proof of one
now the first property we need is that
given a randomized decision tree
Computing app
um
the probability that on input X
that you are going to see a variable in
W1 let's say this probability is at
least one third
so in other words what am I saying so
let T be a randomized DT for f
so for all X
so I've fixed an X sorry let's work with
this X
so the probability
over the randomness of the tree
that
on input X
you have queried a variable from W1
is at least one third okay if I can
leave this here for a second
why is this true
because if you haven't seen a single
variable from W1 then your randomized
tree hasn't distinguished between x and
x with W one flipped right and by
definition of sensitive blocks these
have different values
so
so what we can do now is we can repeat T
several times what is several it's log
block number
and then we expect
that for every X
we've hit all of its blocks
I'm not going to formalize this now I
can formalize it later
and the next property that we're going
to need is that if on input X
you have queried a set s such that s
intersection w i
is non-empty
or all I
so suppose on input X you've queried uh
variables in X and suppose it so happens
that s hits this collection W12 w k
then
we're going to need to conclude that s
is
a certificate
for x
or F at X
what does this mean this means no matter
what input you have
as long as it's consistent with values
in s that you've read
its function if its function value is
the same as f of x
so in other words all inputs consistent
with this is
F monochromatic
so what we are going to argue in here is
we say if you repeat
p in the sense that if you sample from
this randomized decision tree log block
number many times
what's going to happen is that for all X
you are going to see certificates for
them
and now each of these certificates are
going to correspond to F monochromatic
sub cubes
but a certificate is
uh like since we've repeated the tree
only lock block number many of times
there are only a small number of
possibilities of transcripts that you've
read this idea and the number of
transcripts that you've read is exactly
this log block number Times log R6
or R size to the block number and after
taking log 0. this is a very high level
sketch of it
and
a very high level sketch of two as well
why not
so let's fix again X
and let's fix B which is a sensitive
minimal sensitive block of it so this
means
f of x
is not equal to f of x plus b
where f of x plus b is just x with the
values in B flipped
so I'm going to call this input x sub B
for convenience yeah
so now in the input x sub B
foreign
that if you look at x sub B if you flip
the values of B then all single terms in
B are sensitive for X for x sub B
why is this because otherwise you would
have
if any of these are not sensitive then
you would have been able to delete that
from B and you would have a smaller
sensitive block for x
but
so now again using the same property
that we see here
on the input x sub B
uh if you have a randomized decision
tree Computing F on input x sub B
with probability at least one third you
are going to read I
and this is true for all I and B
so in order to show two what we can do
is
um
repeat your original randomized tree
poly n many times and what's going to
happen is
uh
for many sensitive blocks of X you'll
argue that
on those inputs corresponding to those
sensitive blocks on those X of B's
you have read this whole set B in fact
and then what's going to happen is that
each of these you can argue go to a
different leaf
yeah
so if you have several sensitive blocks
for an input X
half of them are going to correspond to
inputs that lead us to Unique leaves in
the randomized this is the very high
level idea and this is formalizable in
fact in a few lines which I don't have
time to write
the other questions
foreign
a couple of minutes addressing log
factors
uh
and people don't really care about log
factors but sometimes it's important to
care about them
and someone has to
go
delete theorem one
okay no worries uh
so let me write down
it's nice because now I can actually put
down the log factors
so this is our theorem one if you work
out all the log factors
and
what I'm going to claim
is that for all f
total
totality is very important and totality
has been important throughout I know
I've been hiding it everywhere but if
you ask these analogous questions for
partial functions they're immediately
known to be false like there are
exponential separations in whatever
measures you care about or we cared
about here at least
[Music]
together
so I'm going to claim this without
a again hand wavy proof for now but if
we have this
then I can replace this by
each of the logins I can replace my log
R sites
so log deterministic decision tree size
is truly polynomically related to log
randomized decision resource
if that's big or Omega
big oh this one
the bottom One login no this is Omega
this is
so this log n I'm upper bounding by log
R size
I guess you'll assume it depends on all
the inputs that's true so f is a total
function okay yeah yeah okay I need F
depending on all inputs you're correct
uh otherwise I'm sure there should be a
simple hack to get around that though
that gives n
hello
yeah I mean yeah
yeah I guess throughout let's maybe from
the beginning of this talk let me go
back and jump and say everything sure
otherwise n doesn't make succeed
right and and also just say a couple of
words about it
so towards the contradiction suppose log
rank suppose randomize size is at most n
by 10 or something
so this means that the randomized query
complexity is at most n by 10.
it actually means that the non-adaptive
randomized query complexity is at most n
by n by 10 also
and this we can show to be not true
fairly easily because F depends on all
inverse
so this is a high level sketch of how we
will show this
so in theorem one we have no log factors
in theorem 2
um
this was relating and query complexity
or very complex deterministic and
randomized here we actually need a login
so if you look at this function there's
the threshold 2 function on N inputs so
in other words this outputs one
if there are at least two ones in your
input and output 0 otherwise
so it's not very hard to show that
any deterministic tree even with and and
or queries
has to have
Omega log n depth
but on the other hand if you even just
allow and queries
so I mean I may need or here maybe
fairly simple construction where you
just sample
a subset of the inputs query its or
query the or of the remaining inputs
check whether they're both one that's
that's the idea repeat this a few times
this gives you a constant cost
randomized or protocol
so this shows that you really need a
login here
so that's the log factors
um
some more things I wanted to talk about
so what are the best possible
separations that we can have so here we
have a okay now let's go back to
ignoring log Factor so here we had a
power 4 separation between log
deterministic size and log randomized
here we have a power three separation
between our query complexity and
randomize or query complexity
um
the first thing I want to say is that
uh D versus
R separation
lifts to
d
and R versus
R and R or D and versus R and separation
what do I mean I mean if you have a
function f witnessing D of f is Omega RF
to the k then you can come up with
another function f Prime that Witnesses
this measure of f Prime is Omega r r
this measure of f Prime
and this was first pointed out to us by
which one we thank you for that
and here's a simple argument for
constructing such an F Prime
is just replace F by F composed with xor
on two input bits so each of your n
inputs just replace it by an xor and two
input bits so you now have a function on
two n inputs
and it turns out that uh
log
B slash R maybe for now size
of f of x r
is
essentially the same as
d slash r
okay so the depth of f somehow
corresponds to log size of f of x r you
can show this
and the same thing holds true for uh
D and of f of x r as well
which in some sense makes sense right I
mean an xor Gadget is obfuscating the
inputs you need to read all pairs in
some sense corresponding to one query
enough you have a blow up in f of x r
okay
so what this means so this just implies
that any separation carries over
um
another thing I want to mention is that
up to log factors
we our result number two
just from these observations here we'll
recover Nissans
D at most R Cube
which also I seem to have erased I had
everything important on this what it
seems
so how do we show that we have D of f
okay
yeah
um
so this
um so basically this and this I'm using
the fact that and query complexity of f
of XR is essentially the same as query
complexity of f
and I want to end with one open question
which I will write here
one letter why not is uh what happens if
you look at Quantum models
so
now in the quantum setting uh for query
complexity
it's known that D over f is at most poly
in Q over f
and I guess it's very interesting to ask
what happens if you also look at Quantum
uh query algorithms with or queries or
width and or queries
can we use similar techniques to try to
so a polynomial relation here I've
thought about it for a while I don't
have answers
yeah I think I'll end here thanks
the question it would suffice to lower
bound with this block number
we've tried that
um it would suffice to lose biased to
lower bound your
um
so maybe I can say another word about
this so uh the way you show that Quantum
is poly related to deterministic or
randomized in the classical in the
regular setting
uh is you have this and then there's
another measure that comes in between
here which is the approximate degree
and if you just plug it as it is
approximate degree of f can't be used as
a lower Bound for Quantum and or Quantum
or context because and
function yes okay
so there should be a variation of
approximate degree that
is at least is not just block number
place by point so there should be an
analog of approximately is at least
square root block sensitivity and I'm
not sure what that analog is it should
be some sort of monomial measure or
approximate L1 non-measure but I'm not
I haven't been able to figure it out
you can look at sides so you can fit the
UC side
instead of
yeah I don't know what happens
yeah right so it's a different measure
but it makes sense to ask about science
I don't know how these related
I have a question so the N of F that you
use here so do you really need this to
be a partition or a cover or does it
matter
um
now in your proof that you will CRM one
yeah
that's a good point I need to think
about it but I think we get a cover like
this there's sort of two steps that go
on like
oh
so let's see
so you get a bunch of certificates for
different excels
um
I think for all we know these might
intersect
and I don't even know if you can
guarantee a partition
any more questions
okay
all right